- Do you see them?
- Yup I see them.
- I haven't seen one yet.
- Did I see one?
It's in the corner.
[Talking Behind The Camera]
- Oh my god.
Oh uh oh.
- They're so cute.
[Kittens Meowing]
[Fast Paced Music]
- What's this? You got it.
- [Dave] What do you see?
- [Justin] You can do it.
- What do you see?
- Alright cats.
- I don't know if this was the right shirt
for this interview.
- Can I get a lint roller for Dave?
- We got a lint roller?
What's your favorite body part?
- My favorite body part?
I guess my hands.
- Your own hands?
- Yeah.
Well no I don't like adore my hands.
- Let me see those hands.
It's a good body part.
- Thanks.
Do you have a go to artist
or album you listen to?
- Classic Otis Redding.
Yeah some Sam Cooke.
All in the same vibe.
Any manscaping tips?
- Oh boy.
Oh I was just giving one actually,
which is put your body
lotion in the shower.
- Go on.
- Yeah so you put your
body lotion in the shower
and then you towel off in there.
And then when it's all steamy in there
and then you hydrate your skin
with the lotion and the steam.
- It doesn't get like too wet still?
- That's why I'm saying you
got to towel off in there.
You get nice and dry.
- Got it.
- While the steam is still present.
- Ohh.
- [Justin] What's the best
vacation you've been on?
- My favorite place in
the world is Big Sur.
- Really?
- Well we try to go once
a year for my birthday.
Because for my first birthday
when Allison and I were together
she threw me a surprise party
which was the first time-
- In Big Sur?
- No, it was the first time
I've ever had an anxiety attack.
- Really, let's talk about that.
Did you have the anxiety
attack when the party started
or like when you walked in the door?
- It's kind of mid-party.
When I decided to
- Have your brain break.
- Have one of the special brownies
and things were going good as is.
- That's not a panic attack
that's just an overdose.
Panic attacks happen
when your totally normal
and just like standing there
and then all of the sudden
the world goes apart
like Inception
- You're totally right.
- This is just too much.
I guess this is for me.
So Will Arnett's going to be upset.
Who has more abs Garmadon or Lego Batman?
- Who.
- Now this is true we were
looking at our Garmadon figure
this morning right?
- He's got a long torso.
- He's got a really long torso.
So it's double the abs.
So that'd be technically sixteen.
And if you notice on the actual Lego toy
he has back abs.
- That's true.
- So he does back day too.
So yes he has more than Batman.
Sadly.
What are you doing?
What's it like working
with your significant other
in projects?
- I love it.
It was a little nerve wracking at first
because we were in a
relationship in the movie too
and you hope there's chemistry on screen
because otherwise everyone's watching you.
- Why are they together?
- Exactly.
But ultimately it's easier
than working with anyone
just cause I can't be
fake in front of her.
Anytime there's a false moment-
- She'll call you out.
- Exactly.
- You're like, "Hey what are you doing?"
"You're gonna do it like that?"
- Exactly.
Do you wish that there was
an additional season of The Leftovers
or anything you wish was added
into the show that was cut?
- No I don't wish for another
season and I don't want any,
I feel like the editors and the writers
did a fantastic job of having
everything they wanted in.
- It's nice to be on a show
that kind of goes out on top
though right and leaves
people wanting more?
- I hope so yeah.
I like closed endings so.
In high school how were you different
from the way you are now?
- Oh.
I was a lot more shy.
It took my like senior year to
really come out of my shell.
We were the group in high school
who was throwing the Frisbee at lunch.
We were cool like that?
- Now the brownies are making sense.
- What were you like in high school?
- I was, I matured very very late.
So it was early high school
and even middle high school
was kind of a bummer because
I was a couple heads
shorter than everybody
and still had a high squeaky voice.
And didn't have facial hair
and all the things that make
you cool in high school.
- When did that voice drop?
- I want to say end of sophomore year.
It kind of dropped then I
started doing a sweet 'stache
and that kind of thing and life improved.
But I kind of already had that
sort of Napoleonic mental.
Kind of followed me all
through high school.
If you had the chance to join
the cast of a Broadway show
what would you pick, don't say Hamilton.
- Umm.
- You can say Hamilton actually.
- You've done a lot of
theater haven't you?
- No, I've done theater
but I haven't done musicals
because I can't sing at all.
- A Broadway show, exactly
I'm the same way I can't sing.
My favorite show ever is Book of Mormon.
- Oh that's hilarious.
- So if I could sing
that would be the one.
- Yeah, that would be
the one I would do too.
- What's the biggest risk you've taken
that you feel has paid off?
- I too did skydiving and it paid off.
Just as far as straight up
risks because I survived.
- The scariest part's going up yeah?
- The scariest part I think
is sitting on the edge of the plane
and going, why am I jumping
out of a perfectly good plane?
- There's that moment too.
- Okay last question.
- Last question, what's the craziest rumor
you've heard about yourself?
- That I sleep naked on airplanes.
Yeah.
- Yeah?
Do you know how that originated?
- It's partly true.
- He's just cracking up over here.
- It's a true story.
I got an email from one of my people
who said this is gonna be published
and I then I read the email
and it was that some serious journalist
actually was like, "We
want serious conformation
on whether Justin sleeps
naked on airplanes."
I thought who, that's
against the law first of all.
No one can do that.
- I'd be impressed if you could
get away with that though.
- Wouldn't that just be
hilarious footage though,
of just me getting arrested,
landing in New York,
just like naked and like what,
I sleep naked on planes.
Somethings wrong with you people.
By the way we should point out
that these cats are all up for adoption
with the North Shore
Animal League of America.
So if you like one of these cats
you can call and get them.
Either one of these or one just like em.
And they will tear your house apart
like there's the end of the world.
Kittens are usually like sleepy right?
There usually kind of, not these guys.
(childish music)